mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wir heute endlich meine damen und herren
es mittlerweile schon vierten folge
waren bei dem spiel
dort geht es darum dass wir diese person
sind namens plan und diese person namens
reilly ist so der schulbus und riley hat
uns die challenge gegeben dass wir mit
zehn leuten etwas haben müssen an der
schule also wir müssen uns zehn leute
klären und in der letzten folge wie soll
mit luca hatten wir schon das erste mal
etwas mit einem mädchen und an der
stelle machen wir jetzt natürlich direkt
weiter wir sehen hier schon heidi sagt
wick die unity tendenz wir brauchen zehn
leute mit ihnen etwas haben eine person
haben wir schon drei und ihre crew
checkt allerdings ab und setzt die giana
ja dass unsere beste freundinnen
vielleicht weil du kleinsteinach waffe
sound like that under your skin sagen
wir bad thing of skin jetzt kommt ja
eine dame an der boss chris cris ganz
kurz zur erklärung ist eine
fußballspielerin eine sehr gute
fußballspielerinnen und blair steht auf
mein gott was haben eigentlich für einen
ausschnitt
also sollen sie eigentlich her was mit
uns haben wollen
bsv wie bereits gesagt blair steht auf
chris gebettete hitliste ios broking me
from chris anscheinend apotheke von usd
in at what you see
ich dachte okay das ändert gerade die
komplette situation ich dachte ehrlich
gesagt dass chris in den augen von blair
eigentlich auch nur ein teil dieser kids
challenge sei so von wegen kommen wir
haben was dann schiebe ich nicht wieder
ab sofort stent mäßig allerdings glaube
ich dass blair wirklich richtige
emotionale gefühle für chris entwickelt
hat also wir haben wirklich auf der
einen seite die kids list also diese
zehn leute mit denen wir was haben
müssen um halt reilly zu zeigen hey wir
sind krank
auf der anderen seite ist allerdings
chris und dass die personen die wir
wirklich lieben es wird noch spannend
auf jeden fall you think i can't get
chris sagt blair betts exactly what i'd
say okay denn nur weil du so hässlich
bist du kein abkriegt heißt das ja nicht
dass du jetzt hier unterhält
ich hasse dich just talking gender and
fest christoph school for two weeks
chris came back but i'll never did
laut christa tyler gedrückt
ja wahrscheinlich hat sie den getötet
alter 1
waging golden girl exactly okay ganz
kurz wenn ihr kein englisch können seid
ihr bei diesem projekt hier eigentlich
komplett falsch ich habe mir den ersten
folge immer so ein bisschen neben
herbert setzt allerdings ist es
eigentlich recht einfaches englisch und
ich glaube man sieht auch viel an meiner
körpersprache und auch wie die personen
sich verhalten was das bedeuten könnte
ist als einer unter euch unter zehn
jahre alt sein sollte und kein englisch
kann dann tut es mir ein bisschen leid
aber ich glaube ihr könnt auch irgendwo
verstehen dass ich nicht jeden einzelnen
satz übersetzen muss beispielsweise
exakt lieben heißt halt exakt auf
deutsch und ich glaub ihr wisst was ich
meine aber ihr könnt mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben mit dem sie oben
abstimmen ob ich das demnächst noch
alles übersetzen soll immer so ein
bisschen wichtige sätze oder ob es okay
ist wenn ich das einfach auf englisch
vorleser er sagt auf jeden fall jetzt
dass sie dieser ganzen geschichte auf
den grund gehen muss
but you're right von der europe focus
list also die kids hat auf jeden fall
priorität jenna sagt wie king of stories
ist schon wieder was zu erzählen
girls like this jenny
weiß nicht ob du schon mitbekommen was
über reis einfach einfach also da muss
ich jetzt wirklich eigentlich keine
große story erzählen warum ich die kasse
leer sagt auch die marie luise player
und ich alle wie sie wirklich quasi als
der gleiche mensch ratings mgs but is
that the truth auf kurs mit ok tell you
what happens kanada viktoria füssel ist
ein hotel juli ok also ambler erzählt es
die komplette geschichte warum sie so
sehr hasst wenn wir mit china zusammen
mit ihrer hilfe die nächste person auf
der kiste ist abgearbeitet haben herr
matter what they used car at the extent
to choose okay das ist die kissel ist
[Musik]
wollen wir uns einen typen klären ich
weiß nicht wir haben eigentlich zu
beginn des projektes festgehalten dass
blair lesbisch sein sollen also
homosexuell
allerdings vielleicht sind bisexuell
kommen wir nehmen den typen der sieht so
aus also wir zudem auf jeden fall
er zwingt uns zu und das bildfeld aus so
wolfgang
[Musik]
ja
wolfgang wie nennt man ein rudel wilder
hunde rotte legend the making history
channel song got to the streets von
rocky von wow dann warum nehmt ihr nicht
einfach spotify app ok rocky v mein gott
da kommt wolfgang und seine gang sogar
an deutsche geifer detail doch following
mio mein gott okay er hat ordentlich
viele mädels an seinem leben nie war
sagen die mädels darf sagt wolfgang er
läuft weiter mit seinen leuten die sind
doch alle irgendwie zehn köpfe größer
gefühlt als wir es konzentriert sondern
mit bei groupies ja bei mir genauso ich
gehe raus und wir laufen direkt 40
millionen mädels sind daher massive
problem sagt player where does wolfgang
rihm höher ist also welche kurse belegt
der place colt der eco chamber sagt
jeanette to get myself in watte
backstage okay das habe ich jetzt
beispielsweise gerade falsch ich dachte
mit reverse meinte player von wegen hey
wo hat er seine unterrichtsstunden aber
es geht darum wo er seine musik übt
auftritt et cetera also da müssen wir
jetzt hin mit player wir sind allerdings
wieder bei bleibt zu hause angekommen
once again weitet backstage ein auto
morgens groupies und wisst ihr was das
bedeutet luca muss wieder geld
investieren damit bleher gut aussieht
und wolfgang beeindrucken kann nicht
mittlerweile wirklich dass gewinn
prinzip von dieser app namens apple
sollte und zwar geht es einfach darum
hey die leute sollen versuchen wirklich
alles hinzukriegen mit dieser player und
blabla aber die kriegen das nur helfen
wenn die wirklich geld investieren und
kranke auto zu kaufen
gut kommen ich habe ja millionen auf dem
konto
ein outfit dead drops wolfgang sybase
inc in hua wolfgang musical impressions
of michael jackson
ich bin eine frau soll soll ich mich
jetzt so anziehen michael jackson ja
exactly what you were sagt blair und das
ist so hart nein blass sieht absolut
beschissen aus epping mit michael
jackson school ist ja denn von dem kann
man das leider nicht so ganz behaupten
dass wolfgangs attention for sure und ja
klar natürlich investiert da wieder 20
diamanten ich habe ja noch ein bisschen
was the chamber also blair läuft jetzt
angelaufen
zu ihm wo er übt so genau da tritt er
gerade auf war laut bibel come to watch
wolfgang rihms da standen ca 5 leute
also der als er wirklich ein hammer
musiker wolfgang smy denkt sich blair
sie läuft auf jeden fall es shaken an
den ganzen leuten vorbei hört sich ein
bisschen die musik an einem check up
dead girl philippsthal hearts club band
front okay also werden jetzt durch
gelassen und jetzt steht sie vor
wolfgang und auch mein gott er brauchte
fünf minuten pause looks like wolfgang
spotted something like steven hayne
germany michael jackson jacket kam mit
backstage wegen groß sagte player das
bildfeld aus und wir sind backstage mit
wolfgang helm wolfgang sagt lehr
wolfgang motz ist uns auf jeden fall der
jurist an einem michael jackson jacket
computer direkt rum wie hope i'm not
everything we have it be considered a
trust me your world of destruction who
are waiting to know what you're about
that was just account für den outdoor
also
er wirkt sehr selbstbewusst wolfgang
sagt der software for my fans ok sorry
du model hat die fda und ema ist second
guest songs wie lieber des von sounds
like this thing we have something with
your right direction liste des ok wir
können jetzt entweder ein wildes jazz
gitarren die zeigen dann ein hardcore
drum solo ein oder ein schild sind track
ich bin eher bei dem track ok alles klar
wolfgang das erste sagt er jus
explodiert beim 1 werden sechs sechser
und länderkunde plattform dieser wir
rasieren dieses spiel von vorne bis
hinten allerdings würde ich sagen dass
wir an der stelle in der nächsten folge
episoden mit luca weitermachen werden
weil ihr hörte schon meine stimme ist
noch immer nicht bei 100 prozent
nicht mal bei 20% gefühlt und ich will
dir einfach noch ein bisschen schonen
deswegen hoffe ich auf jeden fall dass
sich das heutige video gefallen aber ich
das getan hat das ist auf jeden fall
einen daumen hoch unter dem video daten
schreibt mir unten in die kommentare
was sich in der nächsten folge episode
machen soll soll ich mir weiterhin
versuchen wolfgang zu klären
und da findet ihr den nicht so cool soll
ich was anderes machen soll ich
vielleicht sogar ganz anderes spiel
spielen schreibt das gerne und in die
kommentare abonniert main kanal falls
noch kein teil der lokalzeitung ihr das
nächste video nicht verpassen wollte
wenn ich schon am dienstag legten auch
die glocke
denn dann kommt ihr eine
benachrichtigung wenn ich neues video
hochladen
es tut mir wirklich leid an meiner
stimme aber ich bin komplett erkältet
möchte allerdings dennoch täglich
irgendein video raushauen weil das
irgendwie ja keine ahnung sondern ziel
an mich selbst ist was ich mir vor ein
paar monaten gesetzt habe aber jetzt
kommt auf jeden fall das auto
[Musik]